Sweetie you handle the hippies all
handles off-brand Yahweh catches ass dad
bear witness!
Now you see my true form.
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this is going to
be my Rick and Morty season 4 episode 9
video there were a bunch of Easter eggs
so we'll break it all down if you're new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to
get all the videos will do a Rick and
Morty merch giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave
your favorite Easter egg from the
episode on the video careful for
spoilers if you have not seen the
episode yet will do top 10 and
Easter eggs as we go along starting with
number 10 the title of the episode which
is childrick of Morty which is a
reference to the early 2000s movie
children of men which is all about there
being one pregnant woman on the planet
obviously in this episode it was a
planet being pregnant but the actual
plot of the episode didn't really have a
ton in common with the plot of the movie
other than the fact that the main
character doesn't have any biological
relation to the woman in the child that
he's trying to take care of during the
episode just like we find out that Rick
doesn't have any relation to the
children that he's trying to take care
of number 9 family vacation most of the
story revolves around the idea that the
family is on a spring break vacation
camping trip on earth jerry demanding
everyone rough it so that he can feel
needed whatever it is they do they
convince Rick that he has to go along
with it too and it seems like Hebrew
grudgingly joins them when the episode
picks up with them in the car though you
can actually see they kind of gone full
national lampoon's vacation the station
wagon that they drive is actually made
to look like the station wagon from that
movie if you didn't notice before it's
always looked like this I guess that
would make Jerry the chevy chase of this
scenario even though technically Rick is
the main character along with Morty's so
the dynamic isn't quite perfect but you
do kind of have that Chevy Chase beverly
d'angelo vibe going on with Jerry and
Beth just at each other's throats but
also loving each other throughout the
entire episode just this incredibly
dysfunctional relationship that they
have summer apparently has a friend
that's named after a cracker Mike
Triscuit she makes a reference to HBO's
euphoria series which is mostly a show
about younger kids doing a ton of club
drugs together getting into trouble if
you've seen Harmony Korine 's 90's movie
kids or requiem for a dream it'd be like
HBO turning those movies into TV series
we learned back during season three
summer really really just wants to get
high all the time which he does a lot
during this episode huffing the
spaceship equivalent of brake fluid
morty spends the entire episode being
obsessed with playing his video games
because he's 14 that's pretty normal for
a 14 year old they actually made a
reference earlier this season to the
fact that his character is written to be
very on brand for 14 year olds number 8
though Rick's booty call he gets a
phone call from an actual planet that he
calls Gaia turns out even sentient
planets have smartphones that they can
use to communicate across celestial
bodies he MacGyver's himself a Faraday
box to try and duck her call until Beth
demands that they go Beth references
Rick abandoning her as a child again
this is the first real episode in season
4 when they've done the Beth Rick
father/daughter storyline like they did
during season 3 episode 9 dan and Justin
have said that they don't have any
really big plans to answer every single
question about Rick's backstory ever
but based on what bird person told Morty
during season 2 a lot of Rick's time
away from his family when Beth was
growing up when she says that he
abandoned her that was time he spent
mostly fighting in intergalactic wars
getting wasted and screwing around
presumably after his wife was gone and
he's already admitted to that being his
unhealthy way of dealing with his trauma
and speaking of rick's wife we still
don't have any more answers about what
happened to her just the fake memories
that Rick used at Rick the Galactic
government so right now it's even odds
as to whether or not she's still alive
out there somewhere in some dimension or
she really did die we find out that Rick
modified the station wagon to turn it
into a spaceship this is the first time
we've seen this but it doesn't seem like
it should be a huge surprise given how
much he's modified the house with
defensive and offensive technology I
wouldn't be surprised if at some point
he reveals that the entire house itself
is capable of transforming into a
spaceship I love that he built a
function that swaps his seat with
Jerry's like he planned for this
specific scenario in advance knowing
that he was going to have to go on a family
car trip with them when the spaceship
transforms it actually looks a little
bit more like the car that Homer Simpson
designed on The Simpsons with the wings
the number 7
Rick reveals that he actually screwed a
planet Dan Harmon said that this was how
the episode actually started in the
writers room what if Rick did it with a
planet in joke that some writer that day
just didn't feel like doing any work so
throughout the most ridiculous sounding
premise possible and they just decided
to run with it and see if they could
actually turn it into a real episode
Rick tries to explain his kink away by
just saying that he's a scientist he
experiments because that's what
scientists do later they kind of bring
that joke back around in the
post-credits scene when summer catches
him watching the planetary version of
tinder as if he really is getting off on
it most of the time when Rick does crazy
stuff like this it's just to prove that
he's capable of doing it like he wants
to impress other people despite the fact
that he says he doesn't care about that
kind of stuff just be impressed Morty
then number six the gaya planet gives
live birth just like a mammal would the
writers didn't really qualify or explain
the logic behind this story beat like
why would a planet actually give a live
birth I guess you could say it has
something to do with the fact that it's
different because it's a sentient planet
it's kind of like an ego the Living
Planet situation where it can actually
control itself the way that ego can
control his form they get really phallic
with their description of snakes and
even though Beth is the one that's
driving most of this plot early in the
episode rick is not wrong when he
suggests that they just bail and let
evolution handle the parenting all of
Beth's efforts are predicated on the
idea that Rick is actually the father of
all these children and she's just
transferring all of her repressed
traumatic childhood memories of
abandonment onto these alien creatures
so the fact remains at the end of the
episode had they just listened to Rick
and never answered that phone call
everything would have been fine because
as we later learned the kids aren't even
his to begin with so he has no
responsibility to them and even though a
lot of times he comes off in this really
terrible cold unfeeling way he actually
does say later in the episode I'm the
guy that showed up and actually tried to
raise your kids there's just a way to
show you that he's not really that
unfeeling or uncaring he really does
care about his family despite what he
says in a rare moment of solidarity
Jerry agrees with Rick on something that
they should just totally bail but I love
that Beth clearly still has a lot of
issues with Jerry that they haven't
dealt with despite getting back together
at the end of season 3 every day is a
vacation when you're unemployed summer
has the most epic take down of Jerry and
Morty attributes her behavior to her
extended time with Rick but she's been
like this for a long time so I don't
totally think that it's Rick's influence
to blame for her temper then when they
split off the storylines number
five Rick and Beth create their
civilization together as a bonding
adventure Papa bless they actually do
grow closer together it's like a longer
version of their arc during season 3
episode 9 where they started each
other's throats then by the end of the
episode they have this bonding moment
and they come back together during this
whole montage the writers try to make as
many generic cultural jokes and
references to TV and movie tropes as
possible discussing their plans for how
to evolve the children into a full-blown
society like you have all these
different pipes and valves feeding
different personalities and job
functions like the civilization will
only work if they feed all these tropes
from movies and TV shows like making
sure that all their lawyers avoid the
ethics tubes in the joke about routing
athletes so that they can bully
mathematicians forcing them to evolve
into astronomers like that's the only
way to make someone want to be an
astronomer they use this pinball
metaphor to make a whole bunch of Earth
conspiracy jokes that's actually a real
problem on YouTube that Google had to
address a while ago if you can believe
it there are a lot of people out there
that genuinely don't know that the earth
is round the middle-earth joke is just a
Lord of the Rings reference the joke
here about drama writers is that they're
all abused at some point in their life
and that's what makes them want to
become drama writers so the machine here
just spanks them super hard before
sending them into this section they make
a huge joke about therapists needing a
whole bunch of hardcore family news in
order to be effective therapists 20%
isn't enough that I love the joke about
all the unproductive 'z the Jerry is the
DJ's the foodies the influencers when
Rick jokes about recirculating them
through the quote unquote system that's
just a reference to those people
bouncing through their lives having
hundreds of non jobs they make a big dig
about online college being completely
useless when she says that the
workaround to keep the unproductive x'
busy is the same as just shooting them
out of tube in the back to a dump
because this is dan harmon and he also
made community the TV show you could
also call this a community reference
Jerry proves how inept he is when he
winds up falling into the river after
hitting himself with a rock because he
can't even skip rocks properly that's
how dumb he is the reason why the system
determines that Jerry is a worthless
unproductive is just because it was
built by Rick and Beth so it reflects
their values and they think that he's
worthless right now so that's why the
system just spits him out into the
worthless tube
the number for Jerry becomes the leader
of his own tribe of throwaways the
unproductive x' at this point in their
lifecycle are so uh neva l've the Jerry
seems wise by comparison with his
s'mores they just treat him like he's a
god or something and of course it goes
straight to his head but we get another
original song sung by Dan Harmon this
isn't one of my favorites so far but
usually a couple times the season rick
and morty comes up with some cool
original songs one of the funnier things
during this montage though you notice is
that the aliens patterned themselves to
look like jerry's shirts pattern but
then Jerry loses this shirt and copies
them not realizing that they were trying
to copy him in the first place the
moment he gets pissed at one of them for
inventing a cabin is the moment that the
aliens start to evolve past him like
they're actually getting smarter by the
minute later in the episode Rick implies
that this is going to continue to be a
problem until the aliens eventually do
really threaten his life at which point
he'll just blow their ship up the
number-3 Morty and summer spaceship
the alien ship that they find crashed is
actually designed to look like the
exterior of the enterprise-e from Star
Trek The Next Generation movies summer
reminds Morty if I die please don't eat
my ass because apparently that's
something that she needs to warn him
about when they suggest mine slugs and
nebulas that make people see their own
fears that's the riders just implying
that there have been other adventures
that they've been on with Rick in the
past that we haven't seen in episodes
yet but this is meant to be about how
dumb Morty and summer really are with
him thinking the hyper-advanced
spaceship controls are just like his
Nintendo switch video games in Tricia's
bong but as Rick says later in the
episode it's totally okay for them to be
dumb teenagers like that because they
are teenagers he doesn't expect them to
be super smart like he is and when you
really think about it summer is just
looking for any excuse to get high
she'll puff on anything then number two
Rick vs. God we find out that Rick is
actually pretty good at karaoke for at
least certain songs that are in his
register he makes a lion-king circle of
life joke which is obviously Disney
reference they referenced the Disney
Channel later in the episode to the
whole subplot with Rick biting the god
though is a way to give Rick and out
because they don't actually want to end
the episode with Rick having a bunch of
biological children on another planet
the abandoned Rick uses his technology
to replicate a form of the gods powers
which is just a reference to season 3
when Morty call
rigged a really messed up kind of God
Rick says that he's a Zeus and implies
later in the episode that there are
actually multiple Zeus is like he was a
Zeus as if there are more out there
somewhere the fact that the fight just
keeps going on and on is just a
reference to the fight from they live
between Rowdy Roddy Piper and a young
Keith David who you all know is the
voice of the president and a bunch of
other Rick and Morty characters I love
this whole bit with summer huffing the
brake fluid getting super high inventing
the controls telling Morty what to draw
on the dashboard to their credit they do
wind up getting the ship into orbit and
wind up saving Rick even if it's only by
accident but then summer throws up all
over the place
more to get some in his mouth making him
high to their eyes actually look kind of
similar to Rick's blue eyes when he was
doing the crystals back in season one
this is a little bit more hardcore
though morty kind of does the same thing
he did in last week's episode when he
tries to find a moral lesson in their
misadventures but just like rick did
last week after he did that he tells
morty no no no that's not the lesson the
lesson is that video games and partying
are great so just keep doing those
things but the fact that he tells them
he's never going to sell them out then
promptly sells them out five minutes
later is more of the writer's shining a
light on the idea that even though Rick
seems like he has all the answers most
of the time he also lies about stuff all
the time so don't take everything he
says super seriously probably meant as
close as you would get to a GI Joe
knowing is half the battle message from
this show
Rick jokes about summer huffing brake
fluid then promptly takes a puff himself
just for fun because sure why not when
the alien tells Jerry to use the s'more
it's just a Star Wars used the force
reference when Rick says if this was the
real God it'd be a completely different
story he's kind of implying that they
would actually have a chance at killing
the real god they book in the whole
metaphor on parenting in the episode
with Rick's speech talking to the alien
about you know whether or not he's good
or bad he's the parent that actually
showed up to raise her kids jerry
acknowledges he was wrong to try and
force his lifestyle on Morty and summer
and then they acknowledge that they had
been treating him really badly they
effectively reset the family dynamic to
what it was at the beginning of the
episode with Rick's status in the family
being way lower best supporting Jerry
and richest hating being stuck on a
family trip with them so the reason he
throws Morty and summer under the bus
selling them out is just so he
takedown bets and gerry up eggs they
don't feel so high and mighty about
being amazing parents see how terrible
you are and look at all the terrible
things that they did he also kind of
implies that summers going to die in three
days after doing all that brake fluid
unless he does something about it and
then makes fun of the disney channel and
morty for being really really dumb the
number one that whole post credit
scene with rick getting caught watching
tinder for planets on his laptop all the
things that the planets are saying are
actually scientific terms it's just that
are saying them and super funny sexy
salacious voices in apparently this is
Rick's new kink just bringing the joke
from earlier back around in the episode
earlier he said that he was doing this
because he was curious he's a scientist
I experiment which we now know is a lie
because of the way he smiles after
summer calls him out on it like he
really does get off on this it was kind
of a weird concept for an episode I
don't know if it's going to wind up being
one of my favorites but if you spotted
any big Easter eggs in the episode that
I didn't mention in the video just write
them below in the comments the big
reminder though that next week is going
to be the Rick and Morty season four
finale so I'll do a trailer video for
that tomorrow as long as you have alerts
enabled for my channel you should see
that video when I post it but everyone
click here for all my Rick and Morty
episodes and click here for my new
Marvel Wolverine video thank you so much
for watching everyone stay safe
I'll see you guys tonight!